mehdi et nicolas royer qu'on aborde
également la pas venez de niamey mehdi
et et nicolas c'est très simple vous
allez mettre cette vous allez mettre la
borne est dit ici vous allez mettre
cette main géante
ah ouais d'accord cette main géante et
regardez ici il a de la peinture on va
jouer aux dés en sang vous allez avoir
deux des émois de départ à la main
droite
vous voulez produit ce que vous les
prenez la main droite d'accord gers et
les blâmes à gauche n'a pas coulé sous
les 2 sens tu vas jouer avec monique aux
attentes et n y qu il a pas besoin de
fausse main ça m'allait déjà comme ça
nico de ses bourreaux a assez alors
attention on va jouer avec dédé
asseyez-vous mais il ya de la peinture
ici tu as entre les doigts
ouais ouais j'ai dû me dédouane mon
doigt est là mais dit après bien sûr
j'affronterai nico et qu'est ce que j'ai
envie de lui mettre cette main dans la
gueule parce que la dernière fois qu'il
est venu il m'a fracassé enfin il m'a
fracassé c'est très simple on va tirer
avec l'edd et celui qui fera le plus
petit chiffre
il ya l'autre prendra la main il la
mettra dans la peinture il lui fera un
tableau jour de la pièce ça marche 3
vous pouvez venir vérifier un c3 merci à
fait donc trois jeux teulet mais là donc
il faudrait que je fasse deux ouais
[Rires]
ouais donc tu as pas la rater sur a3 est
inférieur à 9
voici maintenant mais du talent bonjour
quelqu'un
t'as le bonjour quelqu'un me dit t'as le
bonjour
tada atteinte à l'un des taux qui tombe
et adam et je revends talent
talbot gens d'affaires
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est parti attention cette ça
passe il faut aller le chercher le 7
juin
enfin par un spam à l'importation comme
c'est déjà mieux pas non mais si ce pas
si tu fais si son égalité
je vais quand même commencé à plonger
maman quand même des oasis parra s'est
pas tu as fait c'est un peu nous trois
les deux cas c'est fou hein
ouais bah on va sur ferrer ne vous
inquiétez pas
e
[Applaudissements]
je la sens pas du tout 6 alors si ce
gars les étrangers légale avec un psy
c'est dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
je vais la faire main gauche à gauche
avec le pousse à l'envers toi même et ça
m'arrange pas parce que moi j'ai deux
trucs après je veux redevenir comment
vont maintenant parce que mehdi vois je
t'adore tu as le bon jour de la
[Applaudissements]